Cette distinction abjecte entre juifs français et juifs étrangers,
de la part de Zemmour,
m’amène à vous parler du drame
de deux grands penseurs allemands du 20 -ème siècle
(juifs étrangers comme dirait Zemmour).
Deux intellectuels que l'avènement du nazisme
a jeté sur les routes de l'exil :
il s'agit de Hannah Arendt
et Walter Benjamin.
Hannah Arendt se réfugie en France
et arrive à Paris, en 1933.
En mai 1940, elle est internée
avec des milliers des femmes au camp de Gurs.
"Gurs, une drôle de syllabe, comme un sanglot qui ne sort pas de la gorge"
écrivait Louis Aragon.
La jeune philosophe parvient à s'évader,
rejoint Montauban,
puis Marseille
où elle obtient, grâce au Centre Américain de Secours,
un visa pour le Portugal
où elle parviendra à s'embarquer pour les États-Unis
en mai 1941 avec un Visa d'entrée illégal.
Hannah Arendt obtiendra la nationalité américaine
et deviendra une grande philosophe
et elle nous a légué une œuvre distinguée.
Elle nous a laissé
Les origines du totalitarisme,
Eichmann à Jérusalem,
Elle nous a laissé
La crise de la culture
Journal de pensée…
Malheureusement,
Walter Benjamin
n'a pas eu la même chance.
En juin 1940,
il est enfermé au camp de Vernuche près de Nevers.
Puis libéré grâce à des intellectuels amis.
Benjamin fuit vers le sud de la France,
arrive à Marseille et fait une première tentative malheureuse pour quitter la France,
en se cachant dans un cargo.
Le 25 septembre 1940,
avec un petit groupe mené par la militante communiste Lise Fittko,
Benjamin franchit la frontière franco-espagnole,
après une marche harassante de 9 heures,
il arriva à Portbou, en Catalogne,
se présente aux policiers espagnols muni d'un visa américain,
mais malheureusement son visa de transit n’est pas validé.
Il est autorisé à passer la nuit à Portbou
en attente d'être remis à la Gestapo le lendemain.
Benjamin fatigué, désespéré
se suicide la nuit de 26 au 27 septembre 1940.
Walter Benjamin
un grand passeur entre la culture française et la culture allemande,
il a traduit Proust,
il a aimé Paris
il disait : Paris est une bibliothèque traversée par la Seine.
Il laissera après sa mort cet ouvrage unique en son genre
intitulé
Paris capitale du 19 -ème siècle.
Il y a loin
entre le pamphlétaire qui cultive la haine de soi et des autres
et deux autres figures juives
qui portent haut les valeurs de notre commune humanité.